cuéntenos Cómo reciben desde el gremio
esta noticia
Bueno un gusto saludarles a ustedes y a
la audiencia de France veinticuatro para
el caso de la asociación de periodistas
de salvadores un tema que nada más
consolida una estructura que ya se ha
venido manejando con el tema de los
youtubers en cuanto al tema de difusión
de contenidos Y prácticamente el anuncio
de ayer el presidente del Congreso es el
de habilitarles un salón para que ellos
puedan operar sus funciones desde el
congreso directamente y transmitir los
contenidos a lo que Nosotros llamamos en
el mayor de los casos contenido de
propaganda del gobierno que No
necesariamente tiene que ver con un tema
de libertad de expresión del cual
lamentamos de este congreso hay que
recordar que en el año 2022 la apes ha
denunciado que al menos tres a
funcionarios vinculados al congreso es
decir diputados han generado
vulneraciones hacia las y los
periodistas estos sin dejar de lado
desde que entró esta nueva asamblea
legislativa de mayoría oficialista
empezó a restringir el acceso a la
información a la prensa
Es cierto que las y los periodistas
pueden hacer preguntas libres a las y
los funcionarios No es cierto que por
ejemplo estos funcionarios respondan o
den espacio para otros tipos de
entrevistas a los medios independientes
por el contrario se trata de en algunas
ocasiones de restringir esta labor
informativa y lo más preocupante es que
en el caso del presidente del Congreso
se jacta de libertad de expresión cuando
el año pasado en 2022 han habido
reformas legales que criminalizan al
labor periodística y pongo un ejemplo
sobre ello en abril se hicieron reformas
a la ley de protección de pandillas y
también a el código penal que
criminaliza hasta con quince años de
cárcel a periodistas que publican temas
vinculados al régimen de acepción
especialmente el tema del fenómeno de
las pandillas que es un tema muy
sensible en este país y donde casi se
está manteniendo una narrativa única
desde el oficialismo sobre cómo están
haciendo el tema de El Combate a que es
bajo el tema también de la represión y
de vulneración de Derechos Humanos que
es algo que este gobierno no quiere que
se dé a conocer tanto así que en el caso
del Salvador tuvimos que sacar el año
pasado a once periodistas para evitar
que se les fuera aplicada estas reformas
legales porque justamente iban a hablar
sobre tema vinculados a ellos reitero En
el caso de los youtubers que se está
mencionando hay que ver qué tipo de
figura de youtubers están yendo uno de
ellos que veíamos esta mañana en un
monitoreo que hacíamos es un youtuber
que es de apellido Silva que está
vinculado a denuncias de expresiones de
violencia de género hacia las mujeres y
que ahora tiene puerta abierta para
poder entrar al congreso no es bastante
irónico lo que este
presidente del Congreso está haciendo
Entonces yo más bien invitaría a los
diputados y diputadas que si realmente
creen en la libertad de prensa y
expresión uno es que le generen las
garantías necesarias al gremio para
ejercer su profesión en que no le tengan
temor a la prensa para poder responder a
las preguntas en general no solo a los
medios oficialistas y En tercer lugar
que dejen de aprobar reformas legales
que criminalizan nuestro trabajo se
viene entonces también Angélica un reto
para los medios de comunicación
cuéntenos como periodistas que van a
hacer en El Salvador para contrarrestar
esta eventual difusión masiva de
desinformación a través de estos canales
no le pude escuchar Bueno le contaba que
se viene ahora un reto para los medios
de comunicación ahora que se puede
transmitir esta difusión masiva de
información a través de estos canales
qué van a hacer ustedes como periodistas
para luchar contra ello muy brevemente
por favor
básicamente en el caso de los medios
digitales hay esfuerzos de promover y
exacerbar el tema del trabajo del
periodismo investigativo hay un
colectivo recientemente que la semana
pasada publicó el filtro que es una
iniciativa sobre quienes están detrás de
la desinformación y creemos que la
medida de este gobierno tiene que ver
justamente por el lanzamiento de este
proyecto periodístico porque saben
justamente y lo que estamos investigando
desde estos medios digitales